Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Mein Name ist Tim Brittlaff und nach einer kleineren Pause, dem Sommer geschuldet,
melden wir uns wieder zurück, um über die Ukraine zu berichten mit mir und mit Pavel. Hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Ja, und ja, it's been a while. Letzte Sendung war vom 10.
Juni. Wir wollten eigentlich schon ein bisschen früher uns zurückmelden,
aber das hat halt, wie ihr merkt, nicht so richtig geklappt.
Und umso mehr sind wir jetzt hier motiviert, mal wieder klartisch zu machen
und euch die Situation im Krieg um und gegen die Ukraine zusammenzufassen.
Ja, ist eine Menge passiert auf der einen Seite, aber auf der anderen Seite
ist auch wieder mal eine ganze Menge nicht passiert.
Wir fangen mal wieder an mit der militärischen Situation.
Die ist halt so weitgehend unverändert, kann man sagen.
Wir kommen auf das, was sich verändert hat. Wir sehen nach wie vor heftige Angriffe
Russlands täglich auf zivile Infrastruktur und natürlich auch auf militärische Infrastruktur.
Russland hat weiterhin die Attacken mit Schahed-Drohnen, mit ballistischen Raketen
und was sie sonst noch im Arsenal haben verstärkt.
Und hat halt auch in ihrer Sommeroffensive weiterhin ordentlich Leute verheizt
und an die Front geschickt, als gäbe es kein Morgen.
Es sind halt auch alle großen Städte betroffen, insbesondere musste Kiew also
schwer einstecken, Kharkiv.
Das heißt, viele Angriffe gingen auch gegen die Hauptstadt und nicht alles davon
konnte abgefangen werden.
Das ist in der Größenordnung von so Hunderten von Schahets, die gleichzeitig
losgeschickt werden, also wir reden von fünf, sechs, siebenhundert Raketen und
Drohnen in der Summe, die so pro Nacht abgefeuert werden.
Einfach um mit dieser massiven Zahl die Luftabwehr zu überwältigen,
was eben auch leider teilweise gelingt.
Wir kommen auch gleich noch dazu, wie es der Ukraine gelingt, hier gegenzuhalten.
Ja, und auf der anderen Seite gab es halt dann viele Gefangenenaustausche,
aber natürlich auch Gegenangriffe der Ukraine.
Also es wurde vor allem viel wieder die Ölproduktion Russlands angegriffen und
vermehrt eben auch Fabriken.
Man sieht auch, dass die Ukraine in zunehmendem Maße über Raketen verfügt, die Long Range sind.
Also Long Range ist vielleicht der falsche Ausdruck. Also die deutlich weiterkommen,
als das bisher der Fall war.
Da sind so diverse neue Systeme auch in Betrieb genommen worden.
Ja, und es gab viele Angriffe auf Raffinerien und das dürfte auch seine Auswirkungen gehabt haben.
Ich meine, allein jetzt in den letzten zwei Wochen gab es allein sechs erfolgreiche
Angriffe auf Raffinerien, also seit Anfang August.
Das hat unter anderem dazu geführt, dass die Spritpreise in Russland jetzt auf
Rekordniveau sind und Russland mal wieder Sprit aus dem Ausland importieren muss,
vor allem aus Belarus und Kasachstan.
Das war früher auch schon mal der Fall und jetzt wird es aktuell wohl wieder etwas eng.
So was ist natürlich immer relevant, weil es eben etwas ist,
was auch die Bevölkerung merkt.
Normalerweise halten die Medien ja die Bevölkerung möglichst frei von solchen
kriegsbedingten Folgen, aber wenn es an die Kohle geht, dann merkt das natürlich auch jeder.
Ob das jetzt schon in einem Maße stattfindet, wo alle anfangen zu stöhnen,
kann ich nicht sagen, aber ich denke, das russische Volk ist leider leidensfähig
und wird das auch eine Weile wegstecken.
Aber es ist natürlich schon krass, wenn Russland auf all places,
also wo wirklich ausgerechnet Öl normalerweise keine beschränkte Ressource ist,
dass sich das dann hier eben auswirkt.
Und da sieht man halt auch, dass wenn die Ukraine auf diese Produktionsstätten
geht, sie geht ja nicht an die Quelle,
sondern es geht ja an diese verarbeitende Industrie und da eben speziell an
diejenigen, die eben dann so diese zweite Reihe Produktion macht.
Also Benzin, Diesel für die unmittelbare Nutzung mit PKWs und wenn halt diese
Fabriken außer Betrieb genommen werden, dann hat das eben auch Auswirkungen.
Es hat einerseits Auswirkungen auf den internen Preis, hat Auswirkungen darauf,
dass man importieren muss, aber es ist natürlich auch wieder etwas,
was Russland nicht exportieren kann, wenn sie ihren eigenen Bedarf schon nicht gedeckt bekommen.
Andere Angriffe gingen so auf rüstungsrelevante Fabriken, also es gab so diverse
Fabriken, wo angeblich Schahetts produziert werden, aber eben auch so Zulieferfabriken,
Elektronikhersteller,
Chemiefabriken.
Zuletzt traf es eine Heliumfabrik, also Heliumfabrik ist Quatsch,
aber eine Heliumprodukte herstellen, ich weiß nicht ganz genau,
Helium kann man nicht herstellen.
Ja, das wird aus Erdgas extrahiert.
Genau. So etwas oder Saphir-Produktion, all solche kleinen wichtigen Elemente,
die in der Rüstungsindustrie eben eine große Rolle spielen.
Also zusätzlich gab es dann außerdem auch noch einen Angriff auf eine Ölpumpstation
von der Druschpa-Tipeline und da hat sich Ungarn tierisch drüber aufgeregt,
dass jetzt die Ukraine angeblich die ungarische Ölversorgung gefährdet.
Das scheint ja sowieso das einzige zu sein, was Ungarn interessiert.
Also der Außenminister hat sich dann in dem Zusammenhang auch gemeldet,
also der Außenminister von Ungarn.
Also ja, was denn das soll? Das ist ja nicht unser Krieg.
Ich finde das ehrlich ganz schön gewagt, dass Ungarn wirklich als unmittelbarer
Nachbar der Ukraine und potenziell ja sozusagen auch als nächstes Opfer der Russen hier...
Diese Sicht hat.
Und gerade Ungarn, ich meine historisch, der Einmarsch in Ungarn war irgendwie
noch schlimmer und blutiger als die Niederschlagung des Prager Frühlings.
Also da, das verstehe ich nicht, dass, ja, da,
dass Orban und das die Regierung damit durchkommt, so einen Kurs zu fahren,
das ist mir irgendwie ein Rätsel.
Tja, so funktioniert die Propaganda. Hauptsache es gibt genug Feinde,
die man ausmachen kann, was auch immer ist.
Zweitens halt irgendwelche Minderheiten, die alles verhindern.
Oder eben die EU, Europa, alles ganz gefährlich.
Da wird der Russe auf einmal gefährlich eingesehen.
Und in Ungarn wird halt massiv auch Anti-EU-Propaganda gemacht.
Also Ursula von der Leyen ist dort Eines der Hauptziele und da hast du dann
halt auf der Straße einfach, ja,
Propaganda mit von der Leyen und anderen EU-Funktionären, die dann an allem
schuld sind natürlich, was in Ungarn schiefläuft.
In dem Zusammenhang kann man auch nochmal was, eine Meldung nochmal zitieren,
das hatten wir schon lange hier in unseren Notes, aber nie so richtig erwähnt.
Es gab ja mal den Fall, das ist jetzt schon zwei, drei Monate her,
dass die Ukraine ungarische Spione festgenommen hat, die angeblich einen Auftrag hatten auszuloten,
ob die Bevölkerung der Westukraine mit einer Invasion Ungarns okay wäre.
Also das war eine ziemliche What-the-Fuck-Meldung und man muss das auch immer
ein bisschen ein Körnchen Salz nehmen, weil,
in so einer Kriegssituation ist die Kommunikation nochmal ein bisschen problematischer
als ohnehin schon aber es ist halt so.
Also als ich in Ungarn war, ich weiß noch, ich saß im Taxi und habe dann gleich
mal den Taxifahrer gefragt, wie er denn das so sieht oder was er mir so sagen
kann, wie denn das so gesehen wird, der Konflikt und der Krieg.
Und er war dann relativ schnell dabei, so ein Ja und was die Ukrainer da machen,
das ist ja auch ganz schlimm und er erzählte von irgendwelchen Massakern an
Russen und dann war auch relativ schnell mit so einer Erzählung da,
dass ja dann auch die ungarische Minderheit ganz schlecht behandelt wird in
der Ukraine oder behandelt wurde.
Und ich merkte relativ schnell, dass da halt einfach auch viel Propaganda schon
verfangen hat und die Ukraine ist ja auch böse zur Ungarn-Nummer.
Definitiv halt so ein russisches Propaganda-Playbook, was da ausgespielt wird,
was halt Orban halt einfach auch schon seit langer Zeit nutzt.
Ob jetzt es wirklich Pläne gibt, dass Ungarn die Ukraine dann auch noch mit übernehmen will.
Keine Ahnung. Das kann sein, das kann nicht sein, aber es drückt glaube ich
so ein bisschen aus, wie schwierig dieser Konflikt da ist.
Also man würde sich jetzt mal nur vorstellen, die Russen würden jetzt wirklich
die Ukraine einnehmen und Ungarn würde sich dann halt einfach so diesen Teil,
also es gibt ja vielleicht mal so ein bisschen zur Geografie,
Ungarn hat ja gar nicht jetzt so viel Landborder mit der Ukraine,
aber es gibt dann sozusagen noch so eine Region eben westlich der Karpaten.
Und das ist der Bereich,
der eben so eine ungarische Minderheit eben auch noch mit hat und keine Ahnung.
Also ich meine, es ist natürlich absurd, dass jetzt ein EU-Mitglied auf einmal
so ein Landgrab mittragen würde, aber bei Orbán scheinen irgendwie so die Regeln
und Normen sowieso schon ordentlich durcheinander gekommen zu sein.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall alles sehr schwierig. Aber genug über Ungarn,
gucken wir nochmal so ein bisschen da drauf, wie sich das so militärisch entwickelt
hat und da gibt es halt auch eine ganze Menge not so good news.
Und das ist halt generell jetzt die Sommeroffensive Russlands,
die weiterhin davon geprägt ist,
dass einfach die russische Armee auf die Leben ihrer Soldaten halt weitgehend
scheißt und die Leute halt einfach an die Front schickt, solange es irgendwie
geht und das ist jetzt auch so ein bisschen die neue Taktik.
Wir sehen auf der einen Seite, da haben wir ja auch schon viel drüber geredet,
einen Krieg, der jetzt technisch vor allem von der Drohnentechnologie dominiert wird.
Also dieser gesamte Frontverlauf ist so eine Zone von ungefähr 20 Kilometer,
wo sich die Armeen gegenüberstehen.
Russland versucht vorzudringen, Ukraine versucht zu verteidigen und sie verteidigen
das halt vor allem mit Drohnentechnologie.
Das heißt, es gibt so eine Surveillance-Zone, die vielleicht teilweise auch
noch viel weiter ins russisch besetzte Gebiet eindringt, vielleicht bis zu 50
Kilometer, wo man also mit Überwachungsdrohnen zumindest erstmal versucht rauszufinden, okay,
was findet da statt, was sind da für Bewegungen, irgendwelche größeren Truppenmassierungen,
sind da irgendwelche Panzer unterwegs etc., damit wenn das dann halt näher rankommt,
das entsprechend beantwortet werden kann.
Aber die eigentlichen Fortschritte werden einfach mittlerweile dadurch erzielt,
dass man mit sehr kleinen Gruppen, also dass die Russen mit sehr kleinen Gruppen
vorstoßen, teilweise auf Motorrädern.
Das hat sich wohl jetzt so ein bisschen, es wurde jetzt immer populärer.
Wo man sich da denkt, natürlich Motorräder habt ihr sie noch alle,
da hat man doch gar keinen Schutz, gerade nicht vor Drohnen.
Ja, ist richtig. Aber der andere Vorteil ist, man ist halt sehr schnell unterwegs
und diesen Überraschungsmoment dann auszunutzen, das war so ein bisschen die
Idee dahinter und teilweise funktioniert das eben leider auch.
Also das Grundproblem oder Aber es gibt in dem Sinne kaum noch feste oder scharfe Frontlinien,
weil eben in diesen 20,
30 Kilometer Streifen an der Front ist es praktisch nicht möglich,
irgendwie größere Truppenmengen zu konzentrieren, weil die dann sofort Artillerie,
Schläge,
Bomben oder was auch immer an sich ziehen.
Das heißt, dass ja mittlerweile auf beiden Seiten du wirklich alle,
vielleicht alle paar hundert Meter hast du dann zwei, drei Leute an der Front,
die dann da gucken und versuchen dann eben ja den Gegner vom Vordringen abzuhalten.
Oder daneben auf Versorgungswege oder so beteiligt.
Dann schießen und die mit Drohnen angreifen.
Und was die Russen wohl auch machen, also neben den Motorrädern.
Ist dann auch, dass sie so ein Zweierteam losschicken, was dann halt von Drohnen
begleitet wird, die dann quasi für Sicherheit sorgen.
Die das dann ausgauten und diese zwei Leute graben sich dann irgendwo ein,
weit vor der Front und ja,
eventuell machen erst mal nichts, aber schießen dann eventuell auf Zivilisten,
die da vorbeikommen oder wenn es dann die Möglichkeit gibt, beziehungsweise
schicken dann mehr und mehr und mehr und hoffen dann,
dass sie irgendwann in irgendeiner Gegend dann vielleicht ein paar Dutzend oder
50 Leute dann haben oder 20,
30 von diesen Zweierteams und dann so vielleicht zu einem größeren Angriff übergehen.
Aber ja, es ist halt ein Krieg, wie es ihn so, glaube ich, noch nicht gegeben hat.
Mit einfach einer sehr diffusen Front, quasi fast so einem Guerilla- oder Spezialkräftekrieg
in einem 30-Kilometer-Streifen.
Und ja, mit aber eben auch entsprechend großen Verlusten.
Und gab es dann diese eine Stelle, war das jetzt...
Bei in der Nähe von Pokrovsk, wo sie jetzt so eine lange Zunge ist.
Das war dann auch wieder so ein Trigger in den Medien, wo dann auf einmal gemeldet
wurde, Russland hat jetzt irgendwie innerhalb weniger Tage 20,
30 Kilometer Vorstoß gemacht.
Wo man sich dann so bildlich wahrscheinlich vorstellt, dass irgendwie so auf
breiter Front die Panzer rollen und so weiter.
Worum es sich dabei tatsächlich gehandelt hat, ist halt so ein Durchbruch an einer Stelle.
Vermutlich mit der von dir geschilderten Strategie, der einfach eine Lücke gefunden
hat in der Überwachung der Front durch die Ukraine.
Dazu muss man halt auch sagen, die Ukraine hat einfach Personalsorgen.
Es wird immer schwieriger, Leute zu rekrutieren für den Krieg,
weil natürlich einfach verständlicherweise viele auch keinen Bock drauf haben.
Die Frontlinie ist extrem groß und wird durch Russland ja durch die unterschiedlichsten
Vorstöße auch möglichst breit gehalten, damit sie dann ihren Personalvorteil
auch gut ausspielen können.
Und die Ukraine versucht es halt
mit Technologie zu schließen und das funktioniert ja auch weitgehend gut.
Insgesamt sind ja die Vorstöße Russlands nach wie vor glacial, wir hatten das ja schon.
Also eine Schnecke kommt schneller voran und dann ist es natürlich immer total
auffällig, wenn mal so ein größeres Gebiet oder ein längeres Gebiet,
muss man an dieser Stelle sagen, weil groß ist es nicht wirklich,
wenn dort eben sehr schnell Vorstöße vorgenommen werden.
Ukraine reagiert jetzt an der Stelle auch, schickt da Spezialtruppen hin.
Das heißt, da wird dann einfach die Soldatenpräsenz größer sein,
auch sehr viel größer sein als die der Russen. Und es ist auch davon auszugehen,
Dass dieses Gebiet nicht unbedingt gehalten werden kann von den Russen,
weil das eben einfach nur so eine dünne Zunge ins Land ist.
Und es ist natürlich auch den Ukrainern klar, wie wichtig das ist,
genau an der Stelle, nördlich von Pokrovsk, dagegen zu halten.
Weil es ist nicht nur nördlich von Pogrovsk, was eben so einer der schwierigen
Orte derzeit ist, die verteidigt werden sollen,
sondern es ist genauso auch südlich von Kostjan Tynivka,
was so die aktuelle Frontstadt ist, dieser ganzen Städtekette,
die dort in Donetsk ist, bis hin zu Kramatorsk und das ist so der Strongpoint
der Ukraine schon immer gewesen.
Also nicht erst seit drei Jahren, sondern auch schon im Kampf gegen die Russen
im Donbass vor zehn Jahren.
Das ist ja sozusagen nur eine Fortsetzung davon.
Das sind auch Gebiete, die die Russen jetzt nicht ohne weiteres einnehmen werden
innerhalb weniger Tage, aber trotzdem will man sie natürlich so weit wie möglich
fernhalten, um zu verhindern, dass sich irgendwo Artillerie positionieren kann,
die dann Städte beschießen kann etc.
Grundsätzlich hat aber Ukraine eben immer dieses Prinzip, man gibt lieber etwas
Land her als Soldaten und die Russen haben einfach die Strategie,
die geben halt lieber Soldaten her,
als keine Fortschritte zu erzielen.
Und da kommen halt einfach so zwei Prinzipien aufeinander, das geht dann nicht
immer gut, auch wenn sich die Ukraine gut hält.
Das Ganze ist natürlich jetzt von der medialen Wirkung her wieder ein Problem,
aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass wir jetzt hier wirklich von so einem großen
Durchbruch sprechen können.
Vielleicht an der Stelle nochmal so ein bisschen so ein Überblick,
wo denn eigentlich jetzt derzeit der Krieg wirklich tobt.
Abgesehen von dieser Gegend um Pokrovsk, wo die Russen mehr Boden gut gemacht
haben als jetzt an anderen Stellen und es geht halt immer so langsam voran.
Ohne, dass wirklich jetzt nennenswert größere Orte genommen werden konnten,
muss man auch dazu sagen.
Das sind alles Felder, kleinere Dörfer.
Teilweise müssen dann die Ukrainer halt auch Stellungen aufgeben,
wo sie vielleicht schon Barrikaden errichtet haben.
Und das ist jetzt gerade bei diesem Fall, bei Pukowski ist das so das Problem,
dass die Russen sehr schnell irgendwo hingekommen sind, womit die Ukrainer nicht
gerechnet haben, weil ihnen halt die Überwachung ein bisschen verloren gegangen ist.
Und dann konnten die Russen halt auch an Stellen schon vorrücken,
wo die Ukrainer so Fallback-Positions eingerichtet haben.
Also wo kleine Bunker befestigte Trenchlines, was weiß ich, waren und dann wird
es natürlich etwas schwieriger, die dann auch wieder rauszubekommen.
Aber es sind halt nicht viele, also wird ihnen das schon irgendwie gelingen.
Na gut, also diese Region ist ein Problem.
Dann haben wir im Norden bei Sumi halt nach wie vor diesen Vorstoß aus Kursk.
Das ist aber alles weitgehend unter Kontrolle, da passiert derzeit relativ wenig.
Um die Stadt Kupiansk, das ist ja so die Stadt, die bei der großen Rakiv-Gegenoffensive
der Ukrainer wieder zurückgeholt werden konnte.
Da sind die Russen ja jetzt schon seit zwei Jahren dran, dort Fortschritte zu machen.
Da gab es leider dann in den letzten zwei Monaten Flussübertretungen und auch
eine Versorgungsstraße ist dann nicht mehr unter ukrainischer Kontrolle.
Trotzdem ist die Stadt selber noch sicher, aber das ist definitiv auch so ein
Ort, der beobachtet werden muss.
Und im Süden in Saporizhia ist, naja gibt es immer mal wieder Berichte,
aber da passiert eigentlich nicht wirklich viel.
Nachdem die Russen ja mal mit so extrem viel Aufwand,
Damals die Stadt Bachmut eingenommen haben, also das war ja ein fortwährendes
Massaker und damals waren ja noch diese Wagner-Truppen dabei,
die dann diesen Putsch versucht haben und so weiter. Lange ist es her.
Seitdem, und wir reden jetzt glaube ich schon von fast zwei Jahren,
seitdem versuchen die Russen, die nächste Stadt nach Bachmut einzunehmen. Das ist Chassiv-Jahr.
Und sieht jetzt so aus, als ob sie da so, ich sag mal, zu zwei Drittel vorangekommen sind.
Es gab die Meldung der Russen, dass sie das schon jetzt alles hätten.
Die Ukraine hat widersprochen. Aber gut sieht es nicht aus.
Und es kann also sehr gut sein, dass es auch noch eine ganze Weile lang hält,
trotzdem ist es ein bisschen problematisch, weil Chassifia halt auch so ein Highpoint ist.
Also es ist, sagen wir mal so, geografisch eigentlich ein Ort,
den man nicht verlieren will,
weil wenn man den dann verloren hat, das hat sich halt immer wieder im Krieg gezeigt,
wenn man mal so einen strategisch wichtigen Punkt verloren hat,
dann kann es sein, dass man danach erstmal nochmal sehr viel weiter zurückgehen muss,
bevor man wieder so einen Ort hat, von dem man gut aus verteidigen kann.
Gut, das ist noch nicht so weit, aber definitiv wird es einfach Zeit,
dass einfach dieser Krieg an sich beendet wird.
Ja
Und zu guter Letzt kann man auch noch sagen es gibt halt nebenbei auch noch
diesen Cyberwar wie entscheidend der ist ist immer schwer zu sagen,
aber findet halt auch statt, da gab es vor einer Woche den Fall,
zwei Wochen, ich weiß ja gerade nicht genau wie lang es her ist,
dass ukrainische Hacker,
offensichtlich alle Daten von Aeroflot gelöscht hatten Zumindest steht das so im Raum,
was dann dazu führte, dass irgendwie nicht alle, aber so gut wie alle Aeroflot-Flüge
nicht mehr angetreten werden konnten,
weil einfach alle Personal- und Planungsdaten abhandengekommen sind.
Naja, also das ist so die Gesamtsituation, alles nicht schön und auch wenn der
Support der Ukraine insgesamt noch nicht abgerissen ist,
er ist halt einfach auch nicht in einem Maße angestiegen, dass man mal sagen
könnte, man kann jetzt hier den Russen entscheidend was entgegensetzen,
um sie auch mal wieder wirklich zurückzudrängen.
Das findet derzeit halt einfach überhaupt nicht statt.
Noch so ein paar besondere Ereignisse, die erwähnenswert wären?
Ja, also es gibt halt immer mal wieder, also besondere Ereignisse sind vor allem
immer, wenn es so um Flugzeuge geht.
Also die Ukrainer haben eine F-16 verloren, die von den Russen irgendwie abgeschossen wurde.
Es ist nicht ganz klar, wie das stattgefunden hat, aber die hat wohl irgendwie
versucht verschiedene Drohnen abzufangen und ist dann im Laufe dieser Bekämpfung
angeschossen worden und musste irgendwie abstürzen.
Dabei ist auch ein wertvoller Pilot ums Leben gekommen, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Aber die F-16 werden ja nach wie vor weitgehend, nicht nur, aber weitgehend
von der Ukraine als Defensivstrategie benutzt.
Das heißt, die sind im Prinzip fliegende Abwehrmaschinen und bekämpfen halt
Drohnen, bekämpfen alles mögliche, was sie irgendwie abschießen können,
weil sie halt auch gutes Radar haben, schnell oben sind etc.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall sehr wertvoll, dass die Ukraine die hat,
aber sie haben halt noch nicht jetzt so viele, dass sie irgendwie entscheidend
in irgendeiner Form eine Angriffssituation herstellen können.
Also sie haben, übrigens gab es einen ganz interessanten Bericht darüber,
wie denn jetzt die Ukraine ihre F-16s einsetzt.
Und ich meine, das Problem ist, dass das natürlich primäre Ziele für russische Angriffe sind.
Das heißt, weil der Propagandaerfolg ist natürlich groß, wenn es gelingt,
die am Boden zu zerstören.
Und deswegen ist es wohl so, dass die F-16 grundsätzlich woanders landen, als sie starten.
Sie kehren nie zur Startbasis zurück.
Außerdem hat die
Ukraine wohl auch mit westlicher Hilfe so mobile F-16-Supportfahrzeuge zusammengestellt und Gruppen,
die sich so ein bisschen an dem ähnelt, wie das Schweden mit der Gripen macht.
Das heißt, die haben da fünf Trucks im Prinzip mit Personal,
wo sie dann irgendwo hinfahren und dann die F-16 quasi am Waldrand auch betanken
und aufmunitionieren und gewisse Wartungsarbeiten vornehmen können.
Also das ist das, wie die Ukraine das im Moment handelt.
Ist natürlich aufwendiger, als wenn du eine Basis hast, wo die Flugzeuge ständig
hinkommen und dort alles läuft.
Sie scheinen bisher weitgehend damit es zu schaffen,
halt nicht von russischer Artillerie oder Raketen oder Drohnen angegriffen zu werden.
Wobei es natürlich teilweise nicht ganz einfach ist, so rauszufinden,
welche militärischen Ziele die Russen erfolgreich bekämpft haben.
Weil wir natürlich in den Nachrichten über alle zivilen Ziele,
die angegriffen worden sind, das ist natürlich in den Nachrichten,
aber bei militärischen Zielen in der Ukraine ab und zu sickert was durch.
Aber wir können vielleicht, glaube ich, sagen, dass wir da kein vollständiges
Bild haben, was denn jetzt so Angriffe auf militärische Ziele angeht.
Aber zumindest sowas wie wenn eine F-16 zerstört ist oder verloren geht,
das wird dann schon in der Regel öffentlich.
Ganz klar ist es nicht. Und die Zahl, aber auch der F-16 nimmt deutlich weiter zu.
Also was bis jetzt committed ist, ist in der Größenordnung von 100 Maschinen.
Die sind jetzt noch nicht da, aber die sollen so, ich sage mal,
bis Ende nächsten Jahres wahrscheinlich in der Größenordnung eintreffen.
Das ist dann so, ja, allein an F-16 ist eine Menge an Flugzeugen, die schon.
Deutlich mehr ist als die meisten europäischen Luftwaffen.
Deutschland hat ein bisschen mehr, aber so in der Größenordnung.
Allein wird die Ukraine F-16s haben, was Deutschland auch an Kampfflugzeugen hat.
Wobei Deutschland keine F-16 hat, muss man dazu sagen. Nee. Ja, ist richtig.
Es gab auch ursprünglich, bevor F-16s überhaupt zugesagt wurden und die ganze
Debatte noch so in der Öffentlichkeit geführt wurde,
wie hilfreich die doch sein könnten, gab es glaube ich so die Einschätzung,
dass man mit so 100 bis 150 F-16 könnte man den Luftraum sichern in der Ukraine.
Zumindest unter den damaligen Bedingungen. Das mag sich mittlerweile geändert
haben. So oder so ist es aber hilfreich.
Ja, achso. Und vielleicht noch erwähnenswert, Frankreich hat auch Mirage 2000
geliefert. in der größten Ordnung von, ich glaube, zwischen 10 und 20 Stück
irgendwas ist da in der Pipeline.
Und eine davon ist auch verloren gegangen, wenn ich mich recht entsinnen kann.
Wegen eines technischen Defekts, da konnte sich der Pilot aber noch ejecten.
Aber schon mal gut zu wissen, dass die auch angekommen sind und auch schon im
Betrieb sind, auch wenn sie jetzt irgendwie eine verloren haben.
Inwiefern die jetzt einen Unterschied machen, weiß ich nicht.
Ist natürlich auch hier wieder so, neues Flugsystem heißt, Piloten müssen anders
ausgebildet werden, etc.
Das dauert ja auch alles. Insofern habe ich mich eher schon gewundert, wie schnell das ging.
Ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass hier eine Pilotenausbildung schon stattgefunden
hat, bevor das überhaupt verkündet wurde, dass die Franzosen Mirage liefern wollen.
Das schien mir eher im Geheimen vorbereitet worden zu sein.
Es ist halt, ich sage mal, ja,
Du kannst einen Piloten innerhalb von wenigen Wochen so weit qualifizieren, dass er in der Lage ist,
mit einer F-16 zu starten und anderswo wieder zu landen.
Also das ist nur der Weg, komplexe Kampfeinsätze zu fliegen.
Das dauert dann eben Jahre, halt die ganze Technik dann auch so zu beherrschen.
Aber die F-16 zumindest, was jetzt das Fliegerische angeht, weil die eben auch
Fly-by-Wire sind, sind viel einfacher zu fliegen als die russischen Kampfflugzeuge.
Also der Workload ist anders. Und da hatten wir auch schon mal das User-Interface,
das ist halt auch völlig anderes.
Russen haben irgendwie tausende von Schaltern und alles ist irgendwo ein Schalter.
Und bei der F16 gibt es halt mehr so menügesteuertes System,
wo du komplexere Dinge dann durch eine Abfolge von Knöpfe drücken machst,
statt irgendwie, ja, also weniger Knöpfe. aber mehr Knopfdrück.
Ja, ist richtig. Ich hatte das jetzt allerdings natürlich auf die Mirage bezogen,
weil das jetzt sozusagen nochmal ein anderes System ist.
Und es ist natürlich jetzt auch nicht so, dass man nur Piloten braucht,
sondern man braucht auch eine Bodengroh, man braucht auch eine Support-Logistik.
Man muss irgendwie Landeplätze haben, Versorgungsplätze haben,
Maintenance machen können, man muss Leute ausbilden, diese Maintenance auch
durchzuführen, gut durchzuführen, auch unter Stress durchzuführen.
Also von daher ist es jetzt nicht so, ah, wir haben ein neues Flugzeug,
jetzt lass mal mal ein, zwei Wochen da ein bisschen durch Frankreich fliegen
und dann geht's los, juhu.
Sondern du musst ja auch die Technik in dein Combat-System mit einführen.
Funktechnisch das Ding muss verbunden sein. Die Software, die da läuft,
muss in die Einsatzplanungsgeschichten mit eingebunden werden und so weiter.
Also das geht ja bis hoch in die Kommandozentrale und in die strategische Planung
rein, dass man eben diese Flugzeuge auch wirklich nutzen kann.
Es ist ja nicht nur so, dass man jetzt da wie Snoopy irgendwie auf der Hütte
sitzt und dann kurven wir mal so ein bisschen rum und spielt Roter Baron,
Sondern Kampfflugzeuge sind Teil einer komplexen Einsatzkette mit Aufklärungsaspekten,
mit Bekämpfungsaspekten, mit sehr viel Datenkommunikation und einer logistischen
und personellen Planung.
Und jedes neue, andere System fügt natürlich dem Gesamtsystem nochmal mehr Komplexität hinzu.
Also ich meine, die Ukraine hätte sich jetzt in Friedenszeiten sicherlich nicht
für so eine Strategie entwickelt,
wo sie jeden Flugzeugtyp, den sie irgendwie kriegen können, in ihrem Militär
aufnehmen, sondern hätten dann vielleicht auch lieber auf F-16 standardisiert.
Aber jetzt sind sie natürlich über alles glücklich.
Uns immer interessant zu sehen, wie sie es dann doch schaffen.
Und ich wäre auch nicht überrascht,
Wenn sie jetzt schon seit geraumer Zeit Teams in Ausbildung haben,
sowohl Piloten als eben auch Bodenteams, die sich jetzt um die schwedische Gripen herumschaden.
So dass zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo die Schweden sagen, okay hier ist unser Grippenbestand,
das haben sie ja schon angekündigt, dass das kommen wird, aber jetzt können
wir sie auch wirklich liefern,
das ist dann nicht der Tag, wo sich die Ukrainer das erste Mal mit dieser Technologie
beschäftigt haben, sondern sie sind mit Sicherheit jetzt schon dabei,
den breiten Einsatz dieser Maschinen vorzubereiten.
Ja, Plus. Ich meine, das gilt für alle modernen Flugzeuge, die mehr oder weniger
elektronische Kampfführungselemente an Bord haben.
Also egal, ob es jetzt um ein spezielles Flugzeug zur elektronischen Kampfführung handelt oder nicht.
Aber du hast halt die Kommunikationsfrequenzen, du hast halt auf den Flugzeugen
die Detektion von feindlichem Radar und feindlichen Frequenzen,
welcher Teil des Spektrums wird gestört.
Wo sind eventuelle Radars und so weiter.
Auf welchen Frequenzen, welche Typen und all das ist eben auch in der Datenbank
an Bord dieser Flugzeuge,
sodass sie quasi auch die Systeme an Bord mit den,
Sowohl mit den aktuellen Freund-Kommunikationssystemen als auch eben quasi die
russischen Frequenzpläne und die russischen Modulationsarten und so weiter.
Und da ist es auch so, dass ein Teil davon geheim ist,
dass man dann, sagen wir, jede Seite dann auch nach und nach neue Frequenzen
oder neue Modulationsschemen oder so irgendwann einführt, die dann wieder analysiert werden.
Und das ist dann eben auch so ein ständiges Katz-und-Maus-Spiel,
was da im elektronischen Spektrum abgeht.
Und je moderner die Flugzeuge, umso mehr sind sie auf aktuelle Daten angewiesen,
um effektiv sein zu können.
Also speziell auch jetzt im Stealth-Bereich, aber generell, um mal zu wissen,
wo kann ich lang fliegen und wo darf ich auf gar keinen Fall lang fliegen.
Ja, die Russen haben nicht so viel Erfolg, was ihre Kampfflugzeuge betrifft.
Also einerseits ist es den Ukrainern wieder gelungen, auf der Saki Airbase mit
Drohnen mindestens eine SU-30 und ich glaube auch noch ein paar andere,
also eine komplett zu zerstören und noch ein paar andere,
ich habe vergessen, SU-22 irgendwas zumindest zu beschädigen.
Im Prinzip ist das nochmal so ein Nachklapp zu der großen Aktion vor ein paar
Monaten, die wir ja hier ausführlich besprochen haben und den Russen geht auch
immer mal wieder was verloren,
also eine SU-30 ist jetzt gerade im Schwarzen Meer verloren gegangen und so weiter.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein interessanter Bereich der Duftkrieg,
den man nochmal im Auge halten muss und wo im Prinzip die Welt auch noch die
Möglichkeit hat, der Ukraine nochmal einen erheblichen Push zu geben,
wenn halt noch mehr Systeme geliefert werden.
Lohnt es sich jetzt vielleicht auch nochmal einen Blick auf die sonstige Waffentechnik zu werfen?
Es ist ja so, im Krieg, es ist ein permanentes Hin und Her der Optimierung.
Ja, also immer wenn man denkt, oh jetzt ist aber die eine Seite immer voll damit
unterwegs, dann kann man schon davon ausgehen, dass die andere Seite sich auch
wieder was einfallen lässt, wie man das dann wiederum umgehen kann.
Und so läuft es natürlich auch in diesem Ukraine-Krieg die ganze Zeit.
Ich meine, wenn man das jetzt mal über drei Jahre anschaut, allein schon welche
Bedeutung Panzer am Anfang noch hatten.
Mittlerweile gibt es kaum noch Panzerbewegungen an der Front,
weil die einfach durch Drohnen so dermaßen weggeballert werden.
Und ich glaube, man kann jetzt auch sagen, jetzt gehen ihnen langsam wirklich
die Panzer auch aus. Und die, die sie noch haben, hauen sie jetzt nicht unbedingt an die Front.
Deswegen diese geänderte Taktik, die wir vorhin schon besprochen haben.
Produzieren natürlich auch nach, aber die können gar nicht so schnell nachproduzieren,
wie die vorne verloren gehen würden.
Ja, aber nur um keinen falschen Eindruck zu erwecken.
Das heißt jetzt nicht, dass Panzer jetzt wirklich bedeutungslos sind oder nicht
eingesetzt werden, sondern in bestimmten Gegenden schon und da haben sich halt gerade...
Ich sag mal westliche Kampfpanzer, aber wohl auch der Marder ganz, ganz gut bewährt,
weil die dann schon mit Drohnen nicht ganz so leicht außer Gefecht zu setzen sind.
Also da gab es viele Berichte, wo die dann teilweise von zwei,
drei Drohnen getroffen worden sind und trotzdem noch nach Hause gekommen sind.
Und insofern ist es halt nicht ganz schwarz und nicht ganz weiß. Also so Panzer.
Nein, nein, ist richtig. Auch die Bradleys haben da auch ähnliche Erfolge erzielt.
Aber man sieht nicht, dass größere Durchbrüche und Vorstöße derzeit mit vielen
Panzersystemen gemacht werden.
Die sind für die Versorgung der Front, fürs Hinterland etc.,
Schutz von Truppen, Verstärkung und auch mal zur Bekämpfung eines Nests super effizient.
Aber es ist jetzt kein Panzerkrieg, den wir jetzt gerade beobachten,
sondern es ist halt primär ein Drohnen- und Raketenkrieg.
Und Flugzeuge, ja, spielen eine gewisse Rolle dabei, aber mehr so als Launcher
und als Verteidiger, aber nicht wirklich Luftkrieg.
Und im Schwarzen Meer hat die Ukraine ohnehin derzeit die Oberhand und da haben
die Russen derzeit relativ wenig zu melden.
So verteilt sich das Ganze. Dann aber ein großes Problem, ich hatte es vorhin
ja schon erwähnt, sind derzeit diese Schahett-Drohnen.
Und zwar, weil Russland einfach mehrere Fabriken aufgesetzt hat,
wo die Dinger einfach massiv produziert werden.
Hunderte am Tag und Hunderte am Tag fliegen halt auch gegen die Ukraine.
Und die Dinger sind zwar eigentlich relativ einfach zu verteidigen,
weil sie ja so langsam sind und so laut sind.
Aber einerseits gibt es jetzt auch so Jet-Drohnen, die sind halt schneller und nicht mehr ganz so laut.
Andererseits ist es halt einfach die schiere Zahl die zu Problemen führt und
die Ukraine hat halt lange.
Rumgeforscht was sie dagegen tun können und jetzt sieht es so aus als ob man
zumindest eine halbwegs brauchbare
Abwehr gefunden hat in Form dieser Interceptor Drones und ich habe.
So eine Art Drohne, vor einem Jahr kam das irgendwie, glaube ich,
auf YouTube so ein bisschen raus, in einem ganz anderen Kontext,
dass, ich meine, es war Red Bull und parallel noch eine andere private Gruppe,
die eine Drohne gebaut haben, die in der Lage sein soll, einem Formel-1-Fahrzeug
zu folgen und das zu filmen.
Jetzt sind ja diese Formel-1-Fahrzeuge schnell unterwegs, so mit 300 Stundenkilometer und so weiter.
Also muss halt auch eine Drohne diese Geschwindigkeit hinbekommen.
Man weiß jetzt von diesen normalen Quadrokoptern, dass die, naja,
schon jetzt in derzeit üblichen Form problemlos 100, 150 Stundenkilometer,
vielleicht auch 200 erreichen kann.
Aber so 300, 400, das ist dann schon wirklich harter Tobak.
Und die Dinger sehen so tatsächlich ein bisschen aus mehr wie so Raketen.
Sind also entsprechend geformt und haben dann quasi die Propeller hinten.
Aber sind eigentlich noch so Quadcopter.
Und es war schon beeindruckend, wie schnell die waren. Und das hat dann,
glaube ich, auch nicht lange gedauert, bis dieses Bauprinzip dann seinen Weg
in den Krieg gefunden hat.
Und das scheint mir jetzt so ein bisschen die Strategie zu sein.
Das heißt, sie sind billig zu bauen.
Das kostet vielleicht 1000 Euro und die werden dann strategisch platziert.
Und wenn halt so eine Schahelddrohne detektiert wird von der Luftabwehr,
dann werden diese Bodendrohnen gestartet, die sich dann eben eigenständig den
Weg zu diesen Schaheldsuchen dort dann explodieren und die Drohne aus dem Kampf nehmen.
Wie da die Zahlen sind, weiß ich nicht genau wie erfolgreich die sind Ja.
Ging mir genauso also es ist glaube ich sogar schon was länger her,
zwei Jahre kann gut sein dass ich auch aufmerksam geworden bin auf diese Bauform
von Drohnen und wie schnell die fliegen und ich dachte mir auch hey,
ich meine das hat auf jeden Fall Potenzial ja militärisches Potenzial diese
Art von Drohnen und in der Tat.
Und es gibt da wohl, gab da auch eine Ausschreibung und es gibt jetzt nicht nur einen Typ,
sondern eine ganze Reihe, irgendwas zwischen fünf oder zehn verschiedene Typen
solcher Drohnen, die jetzt gerade getestet werden und wo man jetzt guckt,
welche funktionieren am besten,
und wo weitet man dann jetzt die Produktion aus.
Und ja, auf jeden Fall scheinen die ganz gut zu funktionieren.
Im Übrigen hat eine von den Dingern, glaube ich, auch einen Hubschrauber abgeschossen.
Das kann gut sein, ja.
Drohnen.
Ja, ähnliche Fortschritte gibt es bei den Bodendrohnen, das haben wir hier auch schon mal erwähnt.
Da geht es jetzt voran, also mit Bodendrohnen meinen wir kleine selbstfahrende
Fahrzeuge, auf die dann alles mögliche montiert wird.
Und so wie ich das mitbekommen habe, hat man jetzt relativ viel Erfolg gehabt.
Also einerseits so als Evakuierungshilfe, also dass man damit Soldaten von der
Frontlinie, die verletzt sind, zurücktransportiert, sowas geht.
Dann flog dann noch parallel so eine Drohne mit, die das sozusagen von oben
sich angeschaut hat und die wurden dann eben fernbedient.
Inwiefern die jetzt schon autonom unterwegs sind, weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe da so meine Zweifel. Aber interessant ist, dass die eben jetzt auch
im aktiven Kampfeinsatz verwendet werden.
Das heißt, da werden dann so Maschinengewehre oder Granatwerfer drauf installiert
und damit an die Front geschickt.
Wie erfolgreich die sind, kann ich nicht sagen. Ich glaube, die taugen auch
nicht unbedingt jetzt immer, weil vermutlich damit auch gewisse Lärm verbunden sein wird.
Die werden jetzt nicht durch die Gräser schleichen.
Aber es ist natürlich eine Alternative zu, ein Mensch läuft da mit der Waffe
in der Hand durch die Gegend und für manche Situation ist das glaube ich ganz gut.
Ich erinnere mich, in der Verteidigung von Avdivka.
Da gab es im Süden der Stadt so eine Stellung an so einer kleinen Brücke wo
die Russen irgendwie monatelang versucht haben durchzubrechen und das nicht geschafft haben.
Bis sie es dann mal geschafft haben und festgestellt haben, dass das,
was die ganze Zeit sie alle abgeschossen hat, so ein automatisches,
fernbedienbares MG war.
Das heißt, da waren überhaupt gar keine Ukrainer stationiert,
sondern die haben das irgendwie aus ein paar Kilometern Entfernung ferngesteuert
und haben immer nur ab und zu mal so eine Versorgungstruppe hingeschickt,
um neue Munitionen dorthin zu bringen.
Aber das Ding war quasi ferngesteuert und von daher sehr effizient.
Also die Ukrainer haben da einige Erfahrungen mit solchen Systemen und Und von
daher überrascht mich das jetzt nicht, dass sie das Ganze auch noch auf so einen
fahrbaren Untersatz mit Reifen oder eben auch mit Kettenantrieb packen.
Ja, wir erinnern zunehmend an Auto-Canons aus diversen Science-Fiction-Filmen
wie bei Alien, wo sie die dann im Flur platziert haben.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du dich an die Szenen erinnerst. Also es ist auf jeden Fall
ein bekannter Strobe, auch so, sagen wir mal, Remote-Auto-Canons,
teilweise aber auch dann mit automatischer Zielerfassung.
Stellst du dann irgendwo hin und wenn da jemand vorbeikommt,
dann eröffnet das Ding das Feuer, ja...
Alles schon mal im Science-Fiction gewesen, jetzt hier auch auf dem Schlachtfeld.
Ja, ansonsten kann man auch erwähnen, dass eigentlich die Ukraine immer mehr selber produziert.
Wir haben ja schon erwähnt, es gibt viele neue Modelle, lohnt gar nicht,
das jetzt hier alles aufzuzählen mit verschiedenen Drohnen, die noch länger fliegen.
Und sie steigern halt sowohl permanent die Payload, also was sie quasi an Sprengmaterial
mitführen können oder eben an Sprit und entsprechend dann auch die Reichweite zu erhöhen.
Außerdem haben sie sich jetzt wohl auch so nach dem russischen Vorbild so ein
Gleitbomb-Kit selbst gebaut.
Das heißt, sie können jetzt die in Anführungsstrichen dummen Granaten,
die normalerweise nur, was weiß ich, vielleicht 20 Kilometer fliegen,
durch so ausklappbare Flügelchen noch sehr viel weiter fliegen lassen,
sodass sie dann irgendwie 60 Kilometer Reichweite haben.
Und generell ist es so, dass die Ukraine wohl mittlerweile gut 40 Prozent,
ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher,
dass ich mir jetzt diese Zahl richtig notiert habe, aber in einem deutlichen
gesteigerten Maße ihre Munition selber produziert.
Und das ist sicherlich halt Artilleriemunition, aber eben auch viele dieser Raketensysteme etc.
Und ja, verschiedene ballistische Raketen werden jetzt auch von der Ukraine produziert.
Also Sapsan.
Und die RIM, die hatten wir irgendwie vor drei Jahren mal diskutiert,
hier auch schon im Podcast.
Ja, ich glaube, Sapsan ist der neue Name der RIM, genau.
Also sie haben sie jetzt irgendwie nochmal weiterentwickelt und wird jetzt wohl
unter dem Namen geführt, ich weiß nicht ganz genau.
Auf jeden Fall ballistische Raketen insofern natürlich ein besonderes Thema,
als dass das, ja das ist was quasi ihr größtes Problem ist in der Verteidigung,
weil die Russen so viel davon haben und so langstreckenmäßig.
Wenn sie jetzt selber ballistische Raketen haben, die über eine lange Strecke
fliegen können, dann eröffnet es nochmal ganz andere Angriffsziele und vor allem
ganz anderes Problem der Abwehr, weil ballistische Raketen sind schwer zu verteidigen.
Die Ukraine kann die eigentlich nur mit den Patriot-Systemen wirklich gut verteidigen.
Und sogar da wird es schwierig,
gerade weil es Berichte gibt, dass die Russen wohl ihre ballistischen Raketen
jetzt nochmal mit so einem Schlingerkurs versehen haben,
wo wohl die Patriot-Systeme so ein bisschen ihre Schwierigkeiten haben,
effizient die Abwehr zu starten.
Ballistische Rakete heißt ja im Wesentlichen die wird einmal abgefeuert und
dann fliegt sie halt einfach ballistisch also quasi mit der ursprünglich reingegebenen
Energie einfach in einer Kurve,
Und steuert nicht mehr nach. Im Gegensatz zu den Cruise Missiles,
die halt Cruising machen, also die links, rechts, oben, unten,
fliegen dann aber nicht so schnell.
Und der Vorteil der ballistischen Raketen ist, die fliegen sehr schnell.
Das heißt, man hat einerseits relativ wenig Zeit darauf zu reagieren,
wenn man sie erstmal detektiert hat.
Dann muss alles sehr schnell gehen, weil die einfach so schnell sind.
Und natürlich ist auch die hohe Geschwindigkeit auch für den Spreng-Impact natürlich
auch nochmal ein Thema. Etwas, was schnell aufschlägt, hat natürlich in sich
schon mal nochmal zusätzliche Energie.
Und insofern wenig überraschend, dass die Ukraine jetzt hier versucht nachzuziehen,
aber da muss halt viele Jahre an Entwicklung reinfließen, um das wirklich effizient zu machen.
Und offensichtlich gibt es diese Fortschritte. Gut, soviel dann vielleicht zu
Waffentechnik und damit auch dem militärischen Teil.
Kommen wir jetzt nochmal zu einem anderen Ding, das poppte vor ein paar Wochen auf Ende Juli,
dass es nämlich auf einmal Demonstrationen gab in der Zivilbevölkerung der Ukraine.
Und zwar nicht nur hier und da, sondern ziemlich flächendeckend in allen größeren
und auch kleineren Städten der Ukraine und da denkt man sich natürlich so,
huch, was ist da denn passiert?
Gibt es jetzt hier einen Aufstand gegen die Regierung? Gibt es jetzt hier einen
Aufstand gegen Selensky?
So wurde das dann natürlich gleich von den Russen gespinnt, dass das jetzt hier
irgendwie wie der Niedergang ist und überhaupt.
Und die Ukraine verliert jetzt hier das Vertrauen in ihren Präsidenten.
Was ist passiert? Also es gab ein neues Gesetz.
Das eine neue Kontrollregulierung beinhaltet hat für zwei Antikorruptionsorganisationen,
die ursprünglich mal eingerichtet wurden nach der Euromaidan-Revolution.
Also der Event, der im Wesentlichen die Russen dann so gegen die Ukraine aufgebracht hat,
als da monatelang auf dem Maidan in Kiew demonstriert wurde und am Ende gab
es halt auch sehr viel Auseinandersetzung.
Am Ende ist aber dann der von den Russen gestützte Präsident musste dann halt fliehen.
Und seitdem ist die Ukraine so halbwegs auf so einem besseren Weg.
Und um halt der allgegenwärtigen Korruption etwas entgegenzusetzen,
wurden diese zwei Organisationen namens NABU und SAP,
nicht zu verwechseln mit unserem SAP, hat damit nichts zu tun.
Die eine ist dafür da zu ermitteln, NABU.
Das heißt die ermitteln unabhängig und schauen sich Korruptionsfälle an wo so
mindestens 80.000 Euro im Spiel sind,
und wenn die dann genug Ermittlungen durchgeführt haben und der Meinung sind
das hat jetzt ein Case, gibt es dann in der Staatsanwaltschaft eine separate
Abteilung, die sich dann darum kümmert das ist diese SAP.
Und das Problem ist jetzt, dass man oder Zelensky, die Regierung, ähm.
Den Eindruck hatte, das weiß ich natürlich nicht, ob da was dran ist,
dass diese Unabhängigkeit dazu geführt hat, dass es russischen Einfluss gab.
Das war so quasi die Unterstellung.
Und deswegen hat dieses Gesetz diese Übersicht über diese Organisation neu geregelt.
Und zwar einerseits, dass die Generalstaatsanwalt eine direkte Kontrolle über
diese durchführende Organisation, diese SAP erhalten soll.
Und außerdem, die auch noch ermächtigt wird, Fälle von diesem NABU,
während die ermitteln, abzuziehen und an andere Abteilungen weiterzuleiten.
Und das war quasi so der Ansatz, damit wollen wir diesen potenziellen russischen
Einfluss, den sie erkannt haben wollen, in irgendeiner Form in den Griff kriegen.
Da gab es halt viel Kritik daran, dass die Proteste sind dann gestartet worden,
wenige Tage bevor dieses Gesetz beschlossen wurde.
Es wurde dann auch beschlossen.
Die Proteste gingen dann weiter und dann gab es halt auch entsprechend viel
mediale Aufmerksamkeit für diesen Fall.
Und ja, die Leute haben sich halt einfach daran gestört,
dass eben diese Regelungen getroffen wurden und man hat auch sehr viel Misstrauen
erzeugt, dass dieses Gesetz, wo das jetzt drin war,
eigentlich ein Gesetz zu was ganz anderem war.
Da ging es um die Untersuchung von verschwundenen Personen an der Front und
dann wurden kurzfristig noch diese Erweiterungen dort mit reingefügt,
die dann das entsprechend neu regeln sollten, wie ich das gerade erklärt habe.
Dann gab es also weiterhin Proteste.
Das waren überhaupt die ersten Proteste dieser Art oder überhaupt irgendeiner Art.
Seit Kriegsbeginn, seit drei Jahren gab es so etwas wie öffentliche Demonstrationen
in der Ukraine nicht. Also vielleicht gab es lokal mal irgendwas,
aber definitiv nichts, was irgendwie städteübergreifend stattgefunden hat.
Und Selenskyj hat dann aber auch auf die Proteste reagiert.
Also das Gesetz wurde zwar jetzt erstmal von ihm unterschrieben,
also es wurde mit großer Mehrheit im Parlament beschlossen.
Dann hat er das auch entsprechend unterschrieben aber dann hat er halt eingelenkt
und hat sich wohl mit der NABU unterhalten und dann einen neuen Entwurf gemacht und der wurde auch,
mittlerweile beschlossen wenn ich mich jetzt nicht komplett irre die ganze Sache
war halt deshalb ein wenig heikel weil,
also nicht nur, dass das jetzt vielleicht auf Misstrauen stieß,
sondern was ja damit auch noch verbunden ist, ist diese Herkunft in dieser Euromaidan-Revolution,
was sozusagen als der Kern des Widerstands gegen Russland angesehen wird.
Und natürlich ist, wenn es um Korruption geht,
abgesehen davon, dass natürlich auch die ukrainische Bevölkerung sich derer
gerne entledigen würde, ist es ja eine essentielle Komponente in der Annäherung an die EU.
Und die EU war dann halt auch sehr schnell dabei und hat gesagt,
so ja Leute, das müsst ihr euch aber nochmal genauer anschauen.
Das Thema ist jetzt vom Tisch.
War interessant zu sehen, wie diese Krise auch gelöst wurde.
Es gab Proteste, die Regierung hat eingelenkt und jetzt redet da erstmal wieder keiner von.
Ich kann jetzt leider nicht genau beschreiben, das hatte ich jetzt vergessen
mir zu notieren, ich habe es irgendwo gelesen,
wie diese neue Regelung aussieht, aber man hat auf jeden Fall diese Kontrollmaßnahmen
entschärft und es ist in anderer Form beschlossen worden und jetzt gibt es auch keine Proteste mehr.
Ja, also ideal ist sowas nicht,
aber sowohl so kurzfristig Dinge irgendwo reinzupacken ist nicht ideal,
aber dass das dann zu Protesten führt.
Also idealerweise möchte man das etwas geschmeidiger gestalten,
wenn Reformbedarf besteht oder im Vorfeld vielleicht schon mal Bedenken ausräumen.
Also insofern, ja, ist nicht hilfreich.
Gut. Kommen wir zum nächsten Punkt.
Da wollen wir nämlich jetzt mal ein bisschen über die Wirtschaft der russischen Föderation sprechen.
Ist so ein bisschen so ein Thema. Ich meine, wenn man sich so YouTube anschaut, gibt es so Kanäle,
deren Überlebensmodell besteht, glaube ich, darin, jeden Tag ein Video zu veröffentlichen
mit dem Titel Russische Wirtschaft steht unmittelbar vor dem Zusammenbruch.
Ja.
Also das ist wirklich, ich kann es schon nicht mehr sehen.
Ja, der Crash, der Unmittelbare wird permanent vorhergesagt und da ist halt
auch was dran, dass Russland zunehmendem Maße wirtschaftliche Schwierigkeiten hat.
Aber was viele halt unterschätzen ist, wie viele Möglichkeiten so ein korruptes Regime hat,
die Dinge so lange umzudichten und umzulenken und andere Leute zu plündern,
die sich nicht ausreichend schützen können,
bevor diese Probleme wirklich in einer Schwächung des Landes und damit natürlich
auch einer Schwächung der Unterstützung dieses Kriegs mündet.
Und nichtsdestotrotz hat die EU ein neues Sanktionspaket verabschiedet am 18.
Juli, um einfach weiter zu verschärfen, was ohnehin schon besteht.
Die EU steht da jetzt relativ alleine, weil USA, kommen wir gleich noch zu,
kann man derzeit komplett eine Pfeife rauchen in dieser Hinsicht.
Und die wirtschaftliche Situation in Russland verschlechtert sich halt auch.
Wie gesagt, verschlechtern heißt nicht, alles ist gleich vorbei,
aber es wird definitiv nicht besser.
Was ist drin in diesem Sanktionspaket? Also erstmal wurde diese Ölpreisgrenze neu definiert.
Da fragt man sich so Ölpreisgrenze, seit wann gibt es denn sowas?
Sowas gibt es halt nicht, aber es ist ja so ein Instrument, was sich die EU
ausgedacht hat, weil sie ja weitgehend Kontrolle über Versicherungsunternehmen hat.
Und Versicherungsunternehmen dürfen dann halt diese Schiffe nicht versichern,
wenn da Öl drauf ist, was halt zu einem bestimmten Preis verkauft wird.
Und die lag bisher bei 60 Dollar. Das hatte so, naja, nur so teilweise Erfolg,
weil halt der Ölpreis an sich schon so weit gefallen ist.
Und jetzt wurde dieser Ölpreis, diese Grenze auf 47,60 Dollar pro Fasten reduziert, pro Barrel.
Aber auch mit so einem automatischen Anpassungsmechanismus versehen.
Das heißt, das ist jetzt so der Startwert gewesen und wenn halt der Ölpreis
insgesamt fällt, dann fällt halt auch diese Grenze.
Also in gewisser Hinsicht ist es so eine prozentuale Regelung.
Der Ölpreis russischen Öls muss so und so viel Prozent, also es ist jetzt nicht
wirklich ein Prozent definiert, aber letztlich läuft es ja darauf hinaus,
sein, damit eben so eine Versicherung noch greifen kann.
Dann wurden noch eine größere Zahl weiterer Tankschiffe auf die Sanktionsliste mit draufgepackt.
Weitere 105, was die Liste auf 444 erweitert.
Das ist schon eine Menge Holz. Ich meine, Schiffe gibt es eine Menge,
aber Russland, das ist halt diese sogenannte Shadow Fleet, von der immer die Rede ist.
Also während die russischen Tanker an sich natürlich sowieso alle sanktioniert sind,
sind halt auch Third-Party-Tanker, die sich von den Russen chartern lassen,
damit indirekt eben auch quasi aus dem Verkehr genommen, weil die dann eben
überhaupt gar keine Transporte mehr haben und in Häften nichts anliefern dürfen.
Und inwiefern jetzt diese weiteren 105 da den Kohl fett machen,
wissen wir nicht, aber besser als nix.
Ja, also Russland spielt da ja so ein Bäumchen-Wechsel-Dich-Spiel mit seinen
Shadow-Fleet-Tankern.
Die werden dann teilweise im Wochenrhythmus umregistriert auf andere Länder.
Teilweise werden dann auch erfundene Versicherungen oder erfundene Agenten eingetragen,
die gar nicht existieren.
Und versuchen dann damit durchzukommen,
was dann auch dazu geführt hat, zu verschiedenen Stops in der Ostsee und auch
einer Eskalation zwischendurch, wo Russland dann wiederum Kriegsschiffe geschickt hat,
um Schiffe der Shadowfleet dann vor dem Borden zu schützen und so.
Also das ist auch ziemlich irre.
Also vielleicht noch mal generell zu der Sanktionsliste oder den Verschärfungen.
Was mich immer erstaunt ist, wie viel offenbar noch nicht sanktioniert ist.
Also wenn dann plötzlich Sanktionen kommen, stellt man fest,
oh, da gab es ja offenbar eine ganze Menge Ausnahmen.
Also diese Sanktionen bisher waren immer löchriger, als man so denkt,
weil es ist ja immer Russland so komplett sanktioniert. Aber das sieht man dann hier immer.
Einmal gut, das Katz-und-Maus-Spiel mit der Shadow Fleet ist eine Sache.
Aber dann, wenn wir uns jetzt die weiteren Sachen angucken,
zum Beispiel, was die Russen auch gemacht haben, ist das Öl dann in irgendwelche
Drittländer exportiert, das dort dann hat raffinieren lassen.
Und dann ging das halt als Benzin und Diesel sanktionsfrei. Das soll jetzt auch sanktioniert sein.
Das heißt, wenn jetzt Drittstaaten russisches Öl zu Benzin oder Diesel verarbeiten,
überträgt sich die Sanktion auf dieses Benzin und Diesel, also auf die Raffinerie-Produkte. Denn,
Irgendwie jetzt für Nord Stream 1 und 2 ein komplettes Transaktionsverbot verhängt,
was irgendwie auch seltsam ist, weil beide Pipelines sind ja außer Betrieb,
aber ich denke, klar gemacht, okay.
Erstens das um Maßnahmen zur Wiederinbetriebnahme oder so wahrscheinlich zu
unterbinden plus mögliche Finanztransaktionen oder dass man sagt,
Ja, wir hatten ja bei Nord Stream,
keine Ahnung, Lieferungen vereinbart und die gehen aber jetzt anderswo lang oder so.
Das hat man jetzt, sagen wir mal, mögliche Schlupflöcher auch einfach geschlossen.
Dann gab es wohl eine tschechische Ausnahme für Ölimporte.
Also Tschechien durfte offenbar russisches Öl noch importieren in bestimmten Mengen.
Das endet jetzt. Und dann neben dem Energiebereich gab es dann einen großen
Finanzbereich, der dann auch sanktioniert wurde.
Also 22 zusätzliche russische Banken wurden sanktioniert.
Und dann aber gab es dann eben auch Sanktionen für Drittländerbanken und gewisse Krypto-Exchanges,
wo irgendwie Sanktionsumgehungshilfe quasi...
Geleistet wird. Das heißt, da sind daneben jetzt dann Banken und andere Finanzorganisationen
sanktioniert außerhalb Russlands.
Oh, the blessings of cryptocurrencies.
Ja, dann außerdem, ja, keine Ahnung, wie relevant das ist, aber Finanzsoftware
darf jetzt auch nicht mehr nach Russland exportiert werden wohl.
Und generell eben weitere Dual-Use-Güter sowie CNC-Maschinen und Chemikalien
sind jetzt auch auf der Sanktionsliste.
Das ist so im Wesentlichen, was dieses 18.
Juli-Sanktionspaket jetzt gebracht hat.
Aber das ist halt auch die ganze Zeit, wie gesagt, ein Katz-und-Maus-Spiel.
Bei den Sanktionen versucht Russland, sobald sie verhängt werden,
wieder Alternativen zu finden, was aber nicht heißt, dass es nicht wichtig ist,
die ständig anzupassen und eben Schlupflöcher, die sich auftun oder die man
vorher aus politischen Gründen nicht stopfen konnte, jetzt allmählich zumacht.
Insofern ist das zu begrüßen, aber es ist jetzt nicht, ich glaube nicht,
dass wir jetzt beim letzten Sanktionspaket angekommen sind.
Also ich denke, es wird Zukunft auch weitere Umgehung und weitere Sanktionspakete geben.
Bis zum letzten Schiff, bis nichts mehr fährt.
Ja, vielleicht nochmal so zu der Bewertung, wie man das so wahrnimmt, mit was...
Woran sieht man eigentlich, dass die wirtschaftliche Situation sich verschlechert?
Wir hatten ja schon mehrfach über verschiedene Faktoren gesprochen.
Die Überhitzung der Wirtschaft primär vor allem dadurch ausgelöst,
dass der Staat sehr viel Geld eben jetzt in die Militärindustrie steckt.
Die Personalnot natürlich groß ist, weil auf der einen Seite viele Soldaten,
hochbezahlt werden müssen, um überhaupt in den Militärdienst zu gehen,
dann tun sie das aber auch und damit werden sie natürlich dem anderen Arbeitsmarkt entzogen.
Und natürlich ist es dann auch attraktiv dann in diese Militärbetriebe zu gehen, die natürlich,
gleichsam verhältnismäßig viel zahlen, um dann eben die Leute auch anzuwerben,
Aber wer dann halt zu kurz kommt, ist natürlich der Rest der Wirtschaft.
Und das führt eben zu dieser extremen Inflation von Dingen, die dann eben einfach
nicht das Militär betreffen.
Das heißt, Lebenshaltungskosten steigen.
Und das führt jetzt auch dazu, dass einfach bei Krediten wie für Immobilien
oder für Autos immer mehr Kreditausfälle zu verzeichnen sind.
Also sie haben sich jetzt irgendwie binnen eines, wie war das,
binnen eines Monats glaube ich verdoppelt.
Und mit anderen Worten, die Leute können einfach ihre Kredite nicht mehr bedienen.
Und wenn halt so viele Leute auf einmal ihre Kredite nicht mehr bedienen können,
dann hat das natürlich das Problem, dass dann auch die Banken irgendwie die
Kohle nicht kriegen, die sie brauchen, um einfach ihrem normalen Kreditgeschäft weiter nachzugehen.
Weil der Sinn von Kredit ist ja, dass man dann eben auch entsprechende Zinszahlungen erhält.
Und wenn die halt nicht kommen, dann ist es ein bisschen scheiße.
Ja, und das Problem ist aber auch, dass eben die Zinsen, also dass die Leute
teilweise für Kredite halt bis zu 30 Prozent Zinsen im Jahr zahlen müssen.
Das heißt, das führt ja natürlich auch gerade zu riesigen Problemen im Immobilienmarkt
in Russland. Also gerade so Projektentwickler stecken natürlich massiv in der
Krise oder generell Neubauten.
So, wenn du dir überlegst, dass du ein Drittel der Kreditsumme jedes Jahr allein
an Zinsen aufbringen musst.
Das macht natürlich dann Kredite viel wichtiger nützlich, beziehungsweise wenn,
selbst wenn man dann eben einen Kredit aufnimmt und du hast dann ein Projekt,
was dann, keine Ahnung, Bauzeiten ein Jahr oder anderthalb Jahre,
dann ist natürlich deine ganze Kalkulation so, ist sehr, sehr schwierig.
Ja, und wie gesagt, wir sehen also wohl jetzt,
also die Ausfallrate hat sich jetzt nur verdoppelt,
aber ja, das ist natürlich trotzdem
signifikant und die Frage ist eben tatsächlich, wie lange die Banken,
das dann tatsächlich durchhalten können. Wobei bei 30 Prozent Zinsen ist natürlich auch, ja,
da kann man dann auch den einen oder anderen Kreditausfall verkraften.
So, ja, und die andere Sache war
noch, Es gab ja diesen großen staatlichen Wohlfahrts- oder Rentenfonds,
wo die Hälfte ja vom Westen beschlagnahmt wurde und die andere Hälfte waren
immerhin auch noch ein paar hundert Milliarden.
Und der scheint aber so allmählich tatsächlich jetzt leer zu werden.
Und in anderen Worten, also der finanzielle Spielraum nimmt ab,
was halt bedeutet im Endeffekt,
dass die Bevölkerung auf lange Sicht mehr zu leiden hat und Dinge einfach nicht
so gut funktionieren. Im Land?
Ja, was auch nicht so gut funktioniert, ist die US-amerikanische Regierung mit
ihrem Super-Luni Herrn Trump an der Spitze.
Ich muss sagen, es ist ich werde schon müde, nur bei dem Gedanken darüber zu reden, weil es einfach.
Die Unerfahrenheit auf einer außenpolitischen Ebene und auch die viel zu offensichtliche
innere Korruption dieses neuen Systems, was einfach im Wesentlichen auf Bereicherung
von Trump und seiner Familie,
basiert und ansonsten eigentlich relativ wenig Verbindung zur Realität hat,
das tut einfach weh.
Und es gab auch viel hin und her,
die relativ deutlich machen, dass mal ganz abgesehen davon, dass da schon die falschen Ziele,
vorliegen beziehungsweise eine Abwesenheit von Zielen auch, also dass es einfach
gar keinen richtigen Plan gibt, sondern dass man einfach nur so ein bisschen
vor sich hin werkelt, dass auch diese Regierung sich einfach selber gar nicht mehr im Griff hat.
Exemplarisch dafür steht der Fall,
dass Anfang Juli die Waffenlieferungen, die schon beschlossenen Waffenlieferungen
wohlgemerkt und finanzierten Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine eingestellt wurden.
Auf einmal flogen keine Flugzeuge mehr von den USA Richtung Europa.
Und alle so, ja, was ist denn jetzt los? Weil es gab überhaupt gar keine öffentliche
Verkündung davon, sondern es wurde halt einfach reingestellt.
Dann gab es so einiges hin und her in der Folgewoche, weil dann die Medien darauf
aufmerksam wurden und natürlich auch mal nachgefragt haben,
bis dann irgendwann Trump sich dazu äußert und meint so, ja nee,
er hätte überhaupt nichts eingestellt, wüsste von gar nichts.
Es fand aber trotzdem statt und es war dann offensichtlich einfach eine eigenwillig
getroffene und nicht mit der Regierung sonst abgesprochene Entscheidung von Pete Hexas.
Dieser Alkoholiker aus dieser Talkshow-Alkoholiker oder Morningshow-Alkoholiker
von Fox News, den Trump zum Präsidenten gemacht hat, weil er die Sendung so toll findet.
Zum Verteidigungsminister.
Entschuldigung, zum Verteidigungsminister gemacht hat. und der dann irgendwie
eigenwillig und der schon immer so sehr anti-Ukraine-mäßig drauf war,
und der dann der Meinung war, das könnte man jetzt halt einfach mal so machen,
das wäre schon irgendwie so richtig so,
wobei dann Trump dem widersprochen hat und dann wurde das wahrscheinlich so
intern so ein bisschen gelöst in Anführungsstrichen.
Am 10. Juli, zehn Tage später, wurden aber diese Lieferungen dann stillschweigend
wieder aufgenommen, als wäre irgendwie nichts passiert. Aber da sieht man schon
mal ganz gut, dass da die linke Hand nicht weiß, was die andere tut.
Also an dem Beispiel, also dieses Trump Statement,
dazu war wirklich Irrsinn und wo ich mich aber dann auch aufrege ist,
wie es denn möglich ist, dass,
Journalisten da nicht wirklich einfach Sturm laufen und darauf reagieren, weil,
Eine Journalistin, glaube ich, hat dann zu Recht nachgefragt,
wie du sagtest irgendwie, ja,
ob Trump denn eingestellt hätte, woraufhin er sagte,
nö, er weiß von nichts.
Aber dann war sozusagen die nächste Frage dann, ja, aber wie es denn sein kann,
dass die eingestellt wurden und er von nichts weiß,
woraufhin er dann nur antwortete im selben Atemzug oder 20 Sekunden später, ja, nee.
Also wenn da was eingestellt worden wäre, dann wüsste ich das auch.
Also ohne mein Wissen passiert hier nichts. Ja.
Also ohne sein Wissen wäre da nichts eingestellt worden, aber er wusste auch
nichts davon, dass irgendwas eingestellt worden ist.
Ja, also der Kaiser ist schon lange nackt, aber keiner traut sich das zu sagen.
Also es ist einfach wirklich ein absurdes Faschoprogramm, was da läuft.
Naja, auf jeden Fall war das Problem dann erstmal wieder vom Tisch,
also das unmittelbare Problem Generell muss man sagen Zelensky scheint mittlerweile
seinen Modus gefunden zu haben mit Trump umzugehen,
Ja Er regt sich halt also das hat er auch schon immer gemacht also er regt sich ja öffentlich nicht auf,
Sondern das ist jetzt einfach der Die wissen, was sie von ihm zu halten haben
und sie wissen, was sie zu erwarten haben und was sie auch immer wieder bekommen ist.
Völlig haarsträubende Äußerungen, Entscheidungen und heute ist Ukraine toll,
morgen sind sie wieder die eigentlichen Täter.
Das wird einfach alles komplett rausgefiltert. Also der Noise-Filter ist extrem.
Trotzdem gelingt es ihnen halt auch immer wieder solche Dinge,
und wir kommen ja gleich zu diesem Alaska-Treffen, da ist es wieder ähnlich,
klug so zu kommentieren, dass sie da so ein bisschen ihren Senf dazugeben.
Andererseits aber auch immer wieder betonen, wie toll das ja alles läuft hier mit den USA und so.
Nie den Namen von Trump selber zu nennen dabei. Sondern immer so allgemein zu bleiben und so weiter.
Und sich damit letzten Endes nicht in eine schlechte Position bringt,
aber trotzdem ihren Punkt so ein bisschen rüberbringt.
Ja, also wenn dann, genau, statt Trump sagen sie Amerika.
Das ist sozusagen die typische Sprachregelung jetzt, wenn sie irgendwie milde
Kritik üben oder irgendwie sagen, Amerika müsste dieses oder jenes tun oder
sollte dieses oder jenes tun.
Oder Amerika sollte sich nicht von Putin über den Tisch ziehen lassen.
Nicht Trump sollte sich nicht über den Tisch ziehen lassen, sondern Amerika.
Das ist dann die offizielle Sprachregelung. Aber man muss auch sagen,
dass bislang sie auch hart geblieben sind.
Aber das kann man dann ein Beispiel, denke ich,
von dem, was jetzt im Vorfeld von den aktuellen Trump-Putin-Gesprächen jetzt gelaufen ist.
Ja, wollen wir da schon hingehen oder hatten wir noch irgendwie.
Also generell was man jetzt vielleicht aber sagen muss, es gab halt jetzt diesen,
täglichen Hin und Her und dann wendete sich ein bisschen das mediale Blatt,
weil es nun sehr offensichtlich wurde und auch in zunehmendem Maße eben in der
Öffentlichkeit diskutiert wurde und auch von der Ukraine immer wieder geschickt
gepusht wurde, dieses Bild.
Putin tut ja nichts.
Also Trump, so der große Friedensbringer, der unbedingt einen Nobelpreis,
Friedensnobelpreis bekommen will, der hat zwar jetzt viel angekündigt und irgendwie, ja.
Man muss nur mit Russland richtig reden und ich bin der Einzige,
der es bringen kann und was weiß ich, in 24 Stunden ist der Krieg vorbei und
all diesen ganzen Unsinn, den er schon vorher von sich gegeben hat,
nur wurde es halt immer offensichtlicher, dass halt nichts passiert.
Und dann fing an, Trump so in der Öffentlichkeit sich zu äußern in der Richtung mit, ja,
er wäre ja jetzt enttäuscht und Putin würde ja ihn gar nicht mehr liebhaben
und das wäre erst mal gar nicht so gut und auf einmal war die Ukraine wieder toll.
Also er drehte so ein bisschen das um und hat sich dann über Russland beschwert.
Und das gipfelte dann in so einem, unglaublich, 50 Tage Ultimatum.
Also 50 Tage, was ist denn das für ein Ultimatum? Ja, wenn Putin sich jetzt
nicht in 50 Tagen mal hier richtig aufstellt, dann ja, or else.
Und naja, wie zu erwarten war, ist da wenig bei rausgekommen.
Also erstmal hat er glaube ich so nach zwei Wochen, weil dann einfach dieser
Zeitraum wirklich zu absurd lang war und der mediale Druck weiter wuchs in diesem Thema,
dann hat er irgendwie gesagt so, ja wir reduzieren jetzt das Ultimatum und jetzt
machen wir noch, was war das am Schluss, fünf Tage oder sieben.
Er sagt das ja auch nicht so genau.
So Ultimatum, ja, so vier oder fünf oder so Tage oder sieben, was auch immer.
Irgendwelche Zahlen, die aus seinem Mund rauskommen. Alles spielt keine große Rolle.
Ja, übrigens, ganz kurz, weil er erwähnt hat, dass er im Wahlkampf gesagt hat,
er wird irgendwie in einem Tag Frieden machen.
Darauf angesprochen jetzt, dass es ja jetzt schon, weiß nicht,
über ein halbes Jahr her ist und noch immer kein Frieden ist,
so, meinte er nur ja, das mit dem einen Tag, das hätte ja wohl jedem klar sein müssen,
dass das sarkastisch gemeint war, dass das nicht ernst gemeint war.
Also wer das ernst genommen hat, ist selber schuld, nach dem Motto, ja.
So ist Trump drauf, deswegen will jetzt ein, also im Grunde genommen müsstest
du jetzt Trump bei jeder Ansage fragen, sagen,
ist das jetzt ernst oder Sarkasmus?
Ja, du kannst einfach nichts ernst nehmen, was Trump sagt, aber das wissen wir, glaube ich, alle.
Ähm, ja.
Und, ähm,
So jetzt aktuell, heute, gerade.
Ja, warte mal, eine Entwicklung war noch interessant, weil was dann die Trump-Regierung
erlaubt hat auf einmal, das klingt auch ein bisschen absurd,
aber immerhin, man muss das leider in dieser Situation als Fortschritt erachten.
Es gab ja seit längerem jetzt schon sozusagen den Strategiewechsel,
dass die Ukraine gar nicht mehr auf kostenlose Waffenlieferungen gedrängt hat,
weil sie irgendwie merkten, da findet irgendwie gar nichts statt.
Stattdessen haben sie ja den Spieß umgedreht und haben gesagt,
wir kaufen den Scheiß jetzt einfach selber.
Und sogar das wollte ja Trump nicht erlauben.
Also es war so dieses wie ihr wollt jetzt hier Petra-Systeme für den normalen Preis erwerben.
Was ist denn das jetzt für eine Nummer? Weil das war ja eigentlich ein geschickter
Hack, weil was sollte man denn da dagegen haben?
Ja, dieses ganze Argument mit ihr nehmt ja unser Geld weg. Ja,
nee, dann kaufen wir das halt einfach.
Über Zusagen der Europäer und so weiter. Also letzten Endes läuft es darauf
hinaus, dass die Europäer jetzt quasi bei den USA ihr Geld abwerfen,
damit die USA Waffensysteme liefern.
Gut, das sind dann zumindest in der Theorie auch neue und moderne Waffensysteme,
könnte man glauben. Wobei das hat natürlich eine Vorlaufzeit und die Ukraine
will Sachen natürlich sofort haben.
Deswegen hat man ja bisher einfach immer aus dem Bestand herausgenommen,
was für die USA ja eigentlich ein super Deal war, weil sie Sachen,
die meistens sowieso hätten verschrotten müssen demnächst.
Also abgelaufene Waffen, Munition, Systeme, die nicht mehr produziert werden,
Flugzeuge, die sowieso erneuert werden und so weiter.
Das war ja einfach eine Fresh-Up ihres Bestandes quasi for free,
weil normalerweise musst du das dann halt teuer verschrotten, den ganzen Kram.
Und so konntest du es halt einfach in die Ukraine schicken, musst den Verschrottungsprozess
nicht bezahlen, sondern nur den Transport.
Und dann kann man halt auch gleich wieder in neue Systeme investieren,
die man bestellt, was man sowieso hätte machen müssen.
Völlig absolut.
Ja, und teilweise Munitionsentsorgung kann richtig teuer sein.
Jetzt hat es zwar keine Zahlen, aber ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass das in manchen Fällen wahrscheinlich den Neupreis übersteigt,
sagen wir jetzt in absoluten Werten, sodass Waffen, die vor 20 Jahren gebaut und bezahlt wurden,
den Preis zugrunde legst du wahrscheinlich dasselbe Nummer für die Verschrottung
oder vielleicht sogar mehr bezahlen musst, Gerade wenn es sich um Sprengstoffe handelt,
die müssen halt von qualifizierten Leuten auseinandergenommen werden und dann
umweltgerecht entsorgt werden.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall wurde das dann erlaubt.
Deutschland hat wohl offensichtlich zwei Patriot-Systeme gekauft und wollte
dann auch noch eine Zusage haben, dass es auch wirklich kommt.
Offensichtlich haben sie die bekommen, sodass schon zwei Patriot-Systeme aus
Deutschland in die Ukraine gewandert sind.
Also da hat Merz relativ schnell entschieden und reagiert und das auch durchgeführt.
Naja, so und jetzt lief es halt auf diese ganzen, auf dieses Ultimatum hinaus,
was sich dann eben verkürzt hat und jetzt wäre es eigentlich auch schon abgelaufen und was kam?
Natürlich keine Sanktionen, keine Maßnahmen, kein irgendwas, sondern Taco Trump.
Hatten wir das überhaupt schon in der letzten Sendung, diese Taco-Nummer hatten wir schon erwähnt.
Also Trump always chickens out. Also immer seine ganzen Ankündigungen,
aus denen dann keine Konsequenzen folgen.
So auch hier. Und er hat dann jetzt
hier wieder sein Golf-Buddy und Immobilienmagnaten Und Steve Wittkopf,
der sozusagen sein Sondergesandter ist für alle Krisenherde dieses Planetens,
wo er sich unmöglich drum kümmern kann, der auch irgendwie keine Ahnung hat,
hat er dann irgendwie nach Russland geschickt und er hat sich mit Putin getroffen.
Putin hat ihm wieder irgendeinen Quatsch erzählt. Den hat er noch nicht mal
richtig verstanden und kam dann irgendwie zurück mit der tollen Ankündigung,
ja, Putin hatte jetzt irgendwie zugesagt, hier irgendwie Frieden gegen Landtausch,
was natürlich für die Ukraine ein absoluter Non-Starter ist.
Ja, die Ukraine wird kein Land weggeben an Putin.
Aber allein diese Ankündigung hatte gereicht, dass dann Trump umgeswitcht ist
und dann gesagt hat, oh ja, jetzt machen wir hier so ein Summit mit Putin und
wir laden ihn in die USA ein. Und zwar nach Alaska.
Nach Anchorage. Auf eine Militärwaffenbasis.
Und da habe ich mich dann gefragt, was zum Teufel Vielen Dank.
Was haben die sich dabei gedacht, Trump und seine Berater, jetzt auf Alaska,
zu ausgerechnet Alaska?
Welches Signal sendet das denn?
Wir treffen uns irgendwie halb auf russischem, halb auf amerikanischem Boden
oder wie? Ich meine, für Russland auf jeden Fall ist das so okay.
Ich meine, das bedeuten, dass Trump eventuell bereit ist,
Alaska zurückzugeben für einen Frieden in der Ukraine oder wie können wir das
jetzt sozusagen Landtausch verstehen?
Also ich meine, ich hätte verstanden, wenn sie sich, keine Ahnung,
Saudi-Arabien, ich meine,
Schweiz geht im Moment nicht, weil die Amerikaner haben gerade ein bisschen
Beef mit der Schweiz und wegen Zellen und so.
Deswegen fällt das wahrscheinlich weg und ja, hätte aber eher erwartet vielleicht
mittleren Osten oder Türkei oder keine Ahnung, aber ausgerechnet Alaska.
Tja, ich meine, was zum Teufel soll das?
Zumal ja die russischen Propagandamedien auch voll davon sind mittlerweile.
Also die sind ja eh beyond. Aber Alaska wollen sie ja auch zurückhaben.
Das war ja auch mal russisch. Das haben ja die Amerikaner, die Russen abgekauft.
Kein guter Deal, würde ich sagen. Aber war nun mal so.
Und das ist auch schon lange, lange Zeit so. Ja, aber jetzt träumen sie auch
noch davon, Alaska holen sie sich ja irgendwie auch nochmal zurück.
Und diese Militärbasis, wo Putin dann empfangen wird im Norden von Anchorage,
das ist vor allem ein antirussisches Spionagezentrum.
Da gibt es irgendwie diese krasse Antennenkonstruktion, wenn man da mal von
oben drauf schaut auf diese Basis, ja,
also eine Monsterabhöranlage, die dann da im Betrieb ist und nur so eine Dinger
und man fragt sich halt so wirklich,
was ist da in...
In Trump gefahren. Aber naja, ihm geht es halt darum, falls du die Antenne mal
sehen willst, ANFLR9 heißt die.
Ein riesen 360 Grad Antennenkonstrukt.
Und worum es ihm geht, ist natürlich klar.
Er will einfach die mediale Aufmerksamkeit und er möchte halt gern mit seinem
Superbody Putin da auf Augenhöhe rauskommen.
Weil er halt ja mit allen tollen Diktatoren und allen in seinen Augen tollen
Führern in irgendeiner Form auf einer Stufe stehen möchte.
Das ist irgendwie alles, worum es geht. Und die werden halt auch da,
also es ist jetzt schon vollkommen klar, you heard it here first,
also was sich in Bezug auf den Krieg, was mit diesem Treffen in Bezug auf den Krieg sich ändern wird.
Das ist hier ein UKW-Exclusive.
Nix. Also da wird nix dabei rauskommen.
Selbst wenn irgendwas dabei rauskommt, die können sowieso nicht beschließen
ohne die Europäer Und schon gar nicht ohne die Ukraine.
Die können ja beschließen, was sie wollen. Die können beschließen,
dass der Ozean morgen gelb ist und dass Russland ganz Europa übernimmt.
Das wird halt nicht passieren.
Was passiert, findet halt leider derzeit noch auf dem Schlachtfeld statt und
solange die USA nicht mal eine klare Position einnimmt und sagt,
Russland reicht jetzt auch, sonst passiert jetzt mal wirklich was.
Aber bisher ist Trump ja nicht bereit, überhaupt irgendwas zu beschließen und
leider war Biden vorher auch zu schwach, um irgendwie mal Amerikas Kraft wirklich zu zeigen.
Naja, also es wird einfach nichts bringen und das wird das Ergebnis sein.
Stattdessen werden sie wahrscheinlich über irgendwelche Mineralien-Deals verhandeln.
Es wurde auch schon gemunkelt, dass sie dann ernsthaft irgendwie über eine Ausschlachtung
der Ressourcen im besetzten Teil der Ukraine verhandeln wollen.
Was natürlich überhaupt nicht geht.
Aber auch Trump angeblich ihnen sozusagen...
Mit ihnen zusammen in Alaska, dass die Russen in Alaska investieren sollten.
Das ist ja noch alberner. Also ich meine, erstens, die Russen haben überhaupt
keine Ressourcen, im Ausland zu investieren auf absehbare Zeit.
Die haben ja jetzt noch nicht mal genug Kohle, um in Russland zu investieren.
Und zweitens wissen sie ja auch, der Trump ist irgendwie so alt,
der stirbt ein paar Jahre und ist dann auch kein Präsident mehr und dann werden
die den Scheiß tun und sich irgendwie von den Russen Alaska, Vor allem, wieso auch?
Also ich meine, was haben denn die Russen überhaupt zu bieten,
was die USA nicht selber haben?
Ich meine, das ganze Geld und die ganze Technologie haben sie.
Ich meine, die einzigen, die sich hier vielleicht ausstechen könnten,
wären die Europäer, die unter Umständen hier noch eine relevante Technik haben.
Aber die Russen haben ja nichts Besseres. Die Russen sind ja selber auf westliche
Technik angewiesen, was Exploration betrifft.
Ja, also alles super absurd.
Und es hat natürlich auch jetzt schon dazu geführt, dass es Proteste in Anchorage
gegeben hat gegen Putin und Russland.
Also da sind schon wohl einige Leute, einige Amerikaner, die das auch überhaupt
nicht toll finden, dass Putin kommt.
Und es scheint nicht sehr populär zu sein, sagen wir es mal so,
dass Trump da Putin eingeladen hat.
Ja, und im Vorfeld auch, weil das natürlich jetzt hin und her war,
hatten dann Selenskyj und auch, ja,
ich glaube, 30 europäische Staatschefs haben sich gestern im Kanzleramt,
so wurde Selenskyj gehostet und wurden dann zugeschaltet.
Und dann hat man sich geeinigt, also sozusagen auf eine ganz klare Liste,
auf eine Position, die zwischen,
ganz Europa oder fast ganz Europa und der Ukraine abgestimmt ist.
Nämlich, dass es keine Gespräche über Territorium geben wird,
bevor ein Waffenstillstand herrscht.
Und dass es eben keine Aufhebung von Sanktionen geben wird, bevor nicht ein
endgültiger Vertrag mit Sicherheitsgarantien da ist.
Und die Sicherheitsgarantien sollen vor allem in Form ja auch einer möglichen
NATO-Mitgliedschaft der Ukraine bestehen.
Das heißt, das ist auch eine klare Forderung.
Ukraine muss frei sein, am Ende ihre Bündnispartner selber zu wählen.
Und dann natürlich zu Dinge, die eher klar sind, Freilassung aller Gefangenen,
Aber zusätzlich wird natürlich auch gefordert, Rückkehr der von Russland entführten Kinder,
was ja auch Anlass ist für den Haftbefehl gegen Putin.
Und man will auch Reparationen zwischen 500 Milliarden und einer Billion Dollar,
also 1000 Milliarden, das soll Russland dann an Reparationen zahlen.
Das ist im Moment die klare Position und ja.
Also die eigentlich sinnvolle Position auch in dieser ganzen Geschichte und
auch eine Position, der sich auch die USA irgendwann nicht mehr entziehen kann,
weil dieses Spiel wird natürlich jetzt so weitergehen.
Putin wird ihn wieder bloßstellen und dann geht es wieder in die nächste Runde
mit irgendwelchen Ultimaten, wo nichts dabei rauskommt und das ist einfach weg.
Wobei Putin wird sich sicherlich von seinen Psychologen gut vorbereiten lassen.
Aber das Problem ist, dass sowohl Trump als auch Putin einfach ein sehr,
verzerrtes Bild der Realität haben.
Und was dann dabei rauskommen soll, ein interessanter Punkt ist ja,
dass Putin oder die Russen bisher glaubten,
Europa sei ein Basall der USA.
Das war bis vor Aber bei nicht Kurzem die Position, also bis Trump,
selbst als Trump dann drankam, dachten die Russen, ja,
Europäer stehen eh, ja, sie machen, was die USA ihnen sagt.
Mittlerweile, wenn man russische Propaganda hört, man hört, ja,
die Europäer machen einfach nicht, was die USA ihnen sagt und deswegen,
was sollen dabei rauskommen jetzt bei diesen Gesprächen mit Amerika,
wenn die Europäer nicht an Bord sind.
Also es scheint so zu sein,
dass zumindest dieser Teil der Realität langsam bei den Russen durchgesickert
ist, dass selbst wenn die USA jetzt einfach den Hahn zumachen,
was sie natürlich gerne hätten,
weil natürlich die USA ist nach wie vor ein extrem wichtiger Faktor,
macht irgendwie wahrscheinlich ein Drittel der Hardware,
der militärischen wahrscheinlich in der Ukraine,
kommt aus den USA und bei einigen Waffensystemen.
100 Prozent, wie bei Patriot-Raketen. Insofern ist die Unterstützung schon kritisch.
Russland wird natürlich alles versuchen.
Um da natürlich auch einen Keil zwischen die USA und Europa zu treiben und so weiter.
Aber ja, am Ende des Tages, wie du schon richtig gesagt hast,
ohne Zustimmung von Europa und der Ukraine wird das nirgendwo hinführen.
Und da auch nur
bei dem Gespräch gestern im Kanzleramt bei der Videoschalte war dann wohl auch
Hexers dabei und dann eben weitgehend isoliert.
Und mittlerweile, also auch noch so ein nettes Detail,
fand ich, seit er im Oval Office kritisiert worden ist, er würde sich nicht genug bedanken.
Bedankt sich jetzt Zelensky ständig, aber er hat sich nicht bei Pete Hexeth
bedankt gestern, aber bei den Das war übrigens Jenny Vance.
Nicht Hexeth.
Ach, Vance, Vance war das, nicht Hexeth.
Der das auch ursprünglich diese Bedankerei ja auch gebracht hat.
Stimmt, das war mit, okay.
Das war aber eigentlich austauschbar alles, aber ja.
Aber ja, also jedenfalls hat sich Selenskyj irgendwie bei Dutzenden europäischer
Staatschefs auf Twitter bedankt für ihre Unterstützung.
Aber eben ja,
Nicht bei Vance. Weil der eben auch keine Unterstützung geäußert hat.
Also alle anderen haben halt Tweets rausgegeben, wo sie ihre Unterstützung ausgedruckt
haben. Und er hat das retweetet bzw.
Zitiert mit irgendwie vielen Dank. Nur von der USA kam nichts.
Sodass es auch nicht gab, wofür man sich bedanken konnte.
Thanks for nothing. J.D. Vance.
No thanks for nothing, würde ich eher sagen. No thanks for nothing.
Ja, no thanks for nothing.
Ja.
Ja, gut. Ich denke, damit können wir unseren Rundblick jetzt auch abschließen.
Gucken, vielleicht kommen wir jetzt mal auch ein bisschen häufiger mal wieder zu Wort hier, weil,
jetzt wird es natürlich interessant werden, was was jetzt hier noch weiter passiert
in dieser ganzen Trump-Putin-Auseinandersetzung.
Und wir wollen ja jetzt auch nicht immer hier nur irgendwie zwei Monate warten,
bis wir uns mal wieder zu dem Thema melden.
Und gucken, wie unsere Vorhersage dann auch zeitnah, wie sich das entwickelt.
Vielleicht liegen wir ja auch mal daneben. Mal gucken. Aber ich bin da eigentlich
ganz optimistisch mit unseren Aussagen.
Ansonsten wollen wir auch versuchen, die versprochene USA-Folge noch nachzuliefern, möglichst bald.
Und ja, ich denke, damit können wir hier erstmal die Tür zuschlagen und bedanken
uns fürs Zuhören und hoffentlich kommen wir auch bald wieder.
Insofern sagen wir Tschüss und bis bald.
Macht's gut. Ciao.